um
how do you feel like because obviously
taylor gang is
has had so many different incarnations
throughout the years
there was like that double xl cover
where it was the lola chick
and shout out to lola juicy and thai
juicy tie yep um
and then it seems like even cardo was on
that cover
cardo shout out to cardo for being so
instrumental in
the sound early on man but then like
more recently you know there's like
you know the guy uh
skate there's you know these younger
artists what's dude's name um
daisy no i'm thinking of a
dude from [ __ ] houston is he from
houston social media social media yeah
yeah yeah for sure
yeah like there's like you know like i
just feel like there's been so many
different but you've kind of always been
the constant besides obviously was
khalifa
um do you remember like the early days
of like
when y'all decided to call the [ __ ]
taylor gang like
like what were like those early days
like you were probably not even chevy
woods yet you were
probably kev i was yeah definitely kev
the hustler kevin hustler yeah
it was it was basically off of like we
didn't
i didn't wear chuck taylors and [ __ ]
right what i'm saying like i didn't
really see those come about
into like outfits until i met wiz
you know i'm saying he was wearing them
with everything you know what i'm saying
and i'm like
what the hell made this dude wear these
shoes bro like these are like some of
the wackest shoes ever
and i'm saying especially to go with an
outfit and like
be in the streets because he was in the
hood with us like i'm saying constantly
like every day
and people would be like yo what's up
with your man bro like what
what what he got on and uh but i just
kind of like
took the time to like figure out why he
moves and why he does the way he why he
thinks this way you know what i'm saying
so
i think that it definitely comes from
the shoe and then
it was just his own thing and then we
came around you know what i'm saying and
then was like 10 of us
from like from like my neighborhood
right right and boom
taylor gang now i guess now he has
something to call it an actual gang of
people
you know what i'm saying so it came from
the shoot and it came from the people
yeah the entire
chuck taylor and and camouflage cargo
short
thing was like uniform yeah it was
uniform for me for like
probably longer than it should have been
[ __ ] cargo shorts bro let me tell you
something
there's something like fire about like
somebody making like a 34
shoe cool for like poor [ __ ]
yeah i could go get me some [ __ ]
chucks and be lit
for the show for the show we used to i
mean we had it was a point where
we used to just wear everybody on tour
like when we were on tour
like you said that was the it was the uh
the shark hoodie the utv
and then it was like you know either a
crew necked that way or
the camo shorts with the pulled up socks
with the chucks
or there were other you got i remember
when liz had like a real flash cloud
kicker hoodie that he put out that was
that
i caught shout out to cloud kicker wow
cloud kicker
that was like that was like the
beginning of like getting close from
people
[ __ ] yeah that shit's crazy like yo we
got a box for you i'm like huh
what's that mean yeah free clothes